bonjour à tous aujourd'hui va parler du
samsung galaxy à 8 j'en ai déjà parlé
dans plusieurs vidéos une prise en main
d'abord ocs à las vegas ensuite une
première vidéo de présentation globale
de ce smartphone ensuite une vidéo on a
testé la caméra avant et la caméra
arrière et maintenant une vidéo où on va
parler de fonctionnalités que vous
donnez cette astuce à utiliser sur le
samsung galaxy à 8 et on va regarder ça
dès maintenant
[Musique]
le 8 c'est le produit phare du tout
début d'année pour samsung
là il ya le s9 qui arrive pour l'instant
on se concentre encore un petit peu sur
108 parce qu'il a plein de choses
intéressantes dans cette vidéo je vous
donnais 7 astuces pour optimiser
l'utilisation de votre galaxy à 8 alors
vous pouvez effectivement dupliquer ses
astuces dans d'autres produits de
samsung et des globalement sur d'autres
produits android mais nous on va se
recentrer sur ses 8 parce que c'est l'un
des produits phares de début 2018 on
parle beaucoup de ce galaxy à 8 en début
d'année parce que c'est vrai que c'est
un produit qui est très sympa dans le
milieu de gamme qui permet de faire pas
mal de choses et que je trouve moi
vraiment très intéressant c'est un
produit que j'ai pu tester prendre en
main grâce à nos partenaires et la faune
points est donc encore un grand merci
donc tout de suite ce qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on va regarder cette astuce
qu'on peut utiliser sur ce produit et
vous allez voir c'est super intéressant
c'est vraiment un point essentiel sur
les smartphones aujourd'hui c'est la
sécurité
vous avez effectivement ici une
reconnaissance de votre visage via la
caméra frontale vous avez effectivement
aussi le lecteur d'empreintes digitales
qui se trouvent ici pour le
déverrouiller vaudois je continue à
penser que l'emplacement n'est pas idéal
cependant toujours à mettre mon doigt la
voilà j'ai toujours un petit peu en
train de salir mon objectif et je trouve
ça vraiment dommage
vous pouvez aussi utiliser le modèle
pour le déverrouiller si votre visage
n'est pas reconnue et vous avez aussi un
code bon le mieux reste quand même la
reconnaissance faciale ou alors
l'empreinte digitale
il est petite astuce qui est vraiment
intéressante pour la turn empreintes
digitales vous enregistre un doigt
premières empreintes et ensuite vous
enregistrer à nouveau le même doigt ça
vous permettra d'avoir plus de zones de
reconnaissance et un déverrouillage
toujours plus optimisé pour votre
empreinte digitale
il faut que vous fassiez vous allez dans
vos paramètres vous allez ensuite
directement sur écran de verrouillage
sécurité vous allez dans lecteur
d'empreintes et vous enregistrer aux
empreintes vous tapez ici a ajouté une
empreinte et vous mettez votre index
ce qui fait que lorsque vous posez votre
doigt comme ça comme ça sur le côté
quelle que soit la position votre
emprunt ne sera reconnu et vous pourrez
optimiser le déverrouillage de votre
appareil
ce que je vous conseille aussi c'est
d'enregistrer effectivement votre index
droit et votre index gauche lorsque vous
le tenez comme ça vous déverrouillerez
rapidement également dans l'autre sens
moi j'ai une critique à faire lorsque
vous le déverrouiller votre smartphone
directement que la reconnaissance
faciale ça marche bien exemple ça
devient roule vite
par contre je veux jouer les lunettes
hop une aide pour filtrer la lumière
bleue et la terreur beaucoup manière
d'un coup
la voyez il reconnaît pas utiliser les
données biométriques où le glissement
pour déverrouiller donc ça veut dire que
dès lors que je mets des lunettes ça
marche pas donc on va très bien cette
reconnaissance sociale elle est bien
moins performante bien moins puissante
caisse rice a dit d'apple il ya un petit
point que je critiquerai le sus au
niveau de la reconnaissance faciale
lorsque vous êtes dans votre écran de
verrouillage de sécurité reconnaissance
faciale vous avez la possibilité
d'activer ou de désactiver ici la
reconnaissance plus rapide ça je trouve
que pour moi c'est une hérésie activer
cette fonction pour accélérer la
reconnaissance désactiver la pour
renforcer la sécurité et rendre plus
difficile le déverrouillage avec une
image ou une vidéo
enfin pour moi c'est la base dire que
lorsque vous déverrouillez votre
smartphone avec la caméra avant voulait
effectivement d'une que ça évite et de
ce soit sécurisé donc si vous avez ici
dans connaissance plus rapide qui n'est
pas du tout sécurisé je vois pas à quoi
ça sert donc pour moi je le décoche
autre astuce qui peut être pas mal c'est
le retour de la touche applications pour
tous ceux qui sont encore nostalgiques
vous avez si effectivement quatre icônes
en bas et si vous voulez avoir une
touche applications pour aller
directement à vos applications
vous pouvez le faire il vous suffit
d'aller dans vos paramètres vous allez
ensuite dans affichage vous cherchez
écran d'accueil et ensuite vous allez
sur touche application hop vous
l'affiché elle va arriver son côté vous
appliquez et ensuite pour trouver vos
touches applications ou directement ici
vous appuyez et vous avez toutes vos
apps alors normalement les applications
vous les avez en montant vers le haut ou
alors en descendant vers le bas
mais bon il ya certains nostalgiques qui
vous rend trouvé cette petite icône ici
vous appuyez vous avez vos applications
c'est très pratique autre astuce que
j'adore avec la caméra vous pouvez
activer bixby vision big bisou permettra
de faire plein de choses super
intéressantes par exemple vous est prit
un bouquin de mathias malzieu j'adore la
mécanique du coeur
vous allez scanner votre texte vous vous
mettiez dessus ça va reconnaître votre
texte donc là ça m'a reconnu mon texte
je vois alors bon le début est un peu
chaotique mais sinon je vais bien j'ai
bien mon texte de la mécanique du coeur
alors bon il ya des choses qu'ils soient
sains précise tous les retours à la
ligne ça mes marques mais dans l'absolu
je peux les dites et je peux faire des
copier-coller jacques ses atouts mon
texte ici et ça c'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment génial en plus de l'extraire
j'ai la possibilité de le traduire
alors ça marche avec google traduction
c'est pas rien il ya des petites choses
au début de petites erreurs c'est pas
génial mais dans l'ensemble c'est vrai
que c'est super alors attention google
trad souvent la trad est pas idéal mais
ça peut vous
on vous donnait quelques bons repères et
c'est vraiment très pratique division et
un truc est aussi super sympa c'est la
correspondance par exemple la regarde et
hop je prends un vieux 33 disent je vais
le photographier ça va le reconnaître
mais ça va me proposer des images
correspondantes donc là j'ai pas notre
33 10 donc ça c'est vraiment sympa donc
ça marche effectivement avec un
téléphone avec plein d'objets vous
pouvez photographier ce que vous voulez
faire reconnaître alors une autre
application qui super sympa c'est sur
les bouteilles de vin donc là j'ai une
bouteille pareil je l'utilisé avec mme
bigbee vision ça mc cauley si la petite
application 20 j'appuie dessus ça va
scanner mauvais et ça va me donner des
informations dessus et ça je trouve que
c'est vraiment super lorsque vous voulez
acheter hors des influences un service
qui est offert avec vino c'est plutôt
pas mal ça me permet d'avoir quelques
informations pratiques rapides
ce qu'on voit effectivement avec big bih
vision c'est que c'est un début on
commencera à l'est effectivement vers de
l'intelligence artificielle mais c'est
bien c'est pas mal vous avez également
un lecteur de qr code
sam scanlon qr code ça nous dirige bien
sur mon site monsieur gros point fr donc
le truc est quand même plutôt pas mal
foutu
une autre fonctionnalité je trouve super
intéressante pour ce smartphone c'est du
point de vue de l'appareil photo vous
avez la possibilité d'avoir la touche
photo flottante
c'est à dire que lorsque vous êtes sur
votre appareil photo vous êtes toujours
le bouton photo qui au même endroit pour
pouvoir déclencher vous mettez la touche
appareil photo flottante et ça vous
rajoute un petit bouton que vous mettez
où vous souhaitez pour faire vos photos
vous pouvez mettre up de l'autre côté si
vous voulez déclenché avec le doigt
gauche et vous en avez la possibilité
vous avez qu'appuyer là vous gardez
votre bouton là vous avez en gros deux
boutons de photos donc je trouve que le
truc est plutôt pas mal foutu
autre point qui est intéressant c'est de
pouvoir customiser la petite barque vous
avez en bas si vous arrivez dans un os
que vous ne maîtrisez pas vous n'êtes
pas encore vraiment à l'aise avec ses
boutons là vous pouvez paramétrer
changer de trois petits réglages alors
comme d'habitude vous allez ici dans vos
paramètres vous allez dans vos
paramètres d'affichage
vous allez fouiller si dans la barre de
navigation vous retrouvé vos boutons
vous pouvez changer la couleur vous avez
la possibilité de mettre quelques
petites couleurs bon effectivement ça
reste très pastel c'est très très très
léger et vous pouvez changer la
disposition des touches vous pouvez
mettre soit récent accueil retour soit
retour accueil récents why not
je trouve que c'est pas mal autre point
qui est super intéressant c'est la
possibilité de filtrer la lumière bleue
on passe de plus en plus de temps sur
nos écrans on s'abîme les yeux là vous
pouvez la filtrer alors j'ai déjà activé
voyez up si je désactive ici je suis
beaucoup plus bleue si je les réactive
je deviens un peu jaune alors faire
attention parce que si vous la poussée à
fond sa faim espèces de marronniers un
peu kaka qui est vraiment pas terrible
vous la mettez un petit peu histoire de
casser le bleu c'est pas mal ça repose
les yeux vous pouvez la mettre tout le
temps où vous pouvez la programmer dire
je ne la veut par exemple que le soir
lorsque je vais me coucher ça c'est
plutôt pas mal moi c'est vraiment une
fonctionnalité qui est super
intéressante et qui va vraiment vous
protéger on n'y pense pas assez souvent
on se flinguent souvent aux yeux sur nos
écrans le fait d'avoir ces chiffres de
lumière bleue jolie pouces autre astuce
qu'intéressante c'est le visionnage de
vos vidéos jouées par exemple une de mes
dernières vidéos je vous la cale en
plein écran vous avez des bords noirs
sur les côtés si vous voulez pas garder
vauban voir vous avez qu à prendre une
vidéo et voulait tirer et là vous
profiter vraiment du plein écran et ça
c'est juste génial
voyez ça c'est d'origine et là c'est
avec le grand écran ça change un peu
l'histoire alors ça va relier un peu la
vidéo mais je trouve que dans l'ensemble
c'est quand même un mal pour un bien
voilà un petit peu pour ses différentes
fonctionnalités de ce galaxy à 8 à la
plein d'autres on peut effectivement
être paramétré de différentes manières
ça dépend des besoins des envies des
goûts de chacun dit mot d'ailleurs vous
si vous avez des bonnes astuces vous
voulez partager en commentaire parce que
je suis preneur et puis c'est toujours
sympa de partager avec tous les autres
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
je savais que comme d'habitude
restez connectés parce qu'on va parler
de plein d'autres sujets d'ici quelques
jours je serai à barcelone
om d'abeilles aussi pour ceux qui ne
savent pas c'est le mobile world
congress c'est un petit peu la grande
messe de la téléphonie mobile
tous les grands acteurs du secteur
seront là tous sauf apple qui
normalement ne sera pas présent mais en
tout cas il y aura énormément de monde
il ya samsung qu'il a présenté son
nouveau s 9 d'ici quelques jours donc
restez connectés on va regarder ce
ensemble d'une manière générale à rester
connectés pascal ivars toujours plus
d'infos pour parler de votre vie
numérique que ce soit des smartphones
des tablettes des caméras d'objets
fonctionnalités d'astuces ya plein de
choses qui vont arriver donc rester
connecté abonnez vous d'ici là soyez
sages portez vous bien je vous embrasse
n'oubliez pas vous
meyer gros bisous ciao salut